[Music]
hello there September is yet another
month packed with great video games
vying for your time and money I'm here
to run you through the best of the month
from the AAA to the free to play and a
few hidden gems along the way this video
is sponsored by twin sales as their
tactical RPG gloomhaven come to console
this month we'll be looking at that a
little later in the video so let's crack
on
we have to start with the biggest game
of the year Baldur's Gate 3 on PS5 what
did you think I was gonna say Baldur's
Gate's console release comes a month
after the PC version which received some
of the highest Collective review scores
ever the thing to note right away is
this is a Dungeons and Dragons game an
RPG with flowing decision making
impacted by dice throws like the board
game and we have ability stats to take
into account too combat is effectively
turn based which then feeds into
understanding how your team attacks the
distance they prefer and of course their
abilities all that said the immersive
storytelling is the glue that keeps
players playing we have a list of
decisions to make regularly and then a
dice roll impacts that choice for
example should you choose to punt this
squirrel achieve a high enough number
and you will absolutely eat it yet fail
and you may miss the kick and miss that
opportunity completely then whatever the
outcome the game just keeps going decide
what kind of character you are and
invest one 100 hours plus into their
Journey Baldur's Gate 3 is an accidental
PS5 exclusive releasing on September 6th
but Xbox fans don't worry you will get
this soon but there is no date just yet
[Music]
next Mortal Combat one I'll be honest I
had to edit this video quite a bit to
miss out most of the bloody scenes as
I'm trying to stay friends with YouTube
this month but I think we all know the
appeal of Mortal Kombat the iconic
fighter is receiving a reboot of sorts
as a new timeline is opened changing the
backstories of beloved characters like
Liu Kang he's the god of fire right now
the evolution of combat continues with
the standard one-on-one fighting
impacted by Cameo Fighters they can be
tagged in for a split second to turn the
tide of battle before leaving again this
brings in a new Tactical element to an
already packed System including x-ray
moves brutal Combos and of course the
voice we long to hear
finishing moves that make me worry about
the sanity of the Mortal Kombat staff
Mortal Kombat 1 MK1 is set to be
released for Playstation Xbox PC and
Nintendo switch on September 19th
here's something that shocked me it's
been 10 years since Payday 2 released
and now a decade later payday 3 finally
arrives the premise is pretty simple
pull off the perfect Heist we are
certified criminals after checking out
the venue whether that's a bank or an
art gallery we plan our attack taking
out cameras unlocking doors and managing
the local security all in the hopes of
grabbing something valuable and escaping
it doesn't have to be a firefight though
it's possible to do an entire job with
stealth pickpocketing guards for key
cards uncovering Intel and staying out
of sight at all times that said 99 of
heists will likely end up with an epic
and explosive Exit Plan and staying in a
mission too long gives the spec Ops Team
hunting you down chance to arrive at
your location payday 3 can be played
alone but the real appeal is heisting
with your friends look out for it on
September 21st on the PS5 the Xbox
series and PC and note this it's
retailing at 40.40 Euros which is 35
quid in the UK
take a look at gloomhaven the
well-received tactical RPG on PC is
making the switch to console on
September 18th the original board game
created by Isaac chaldress is Faithfully
recreated in a ruthless world we must
Venture through it with our band of
mercenaries gloomhaven uses a card
system to dictate movement and attacks
in turn-based scenarios when building
our team we have a selection of
one-of-a-kind mercs to choose from each
with their own abilities with over a
thousand in fact the Gold Edition of the
game includes all the DLC added over the
last two years bolstering more scenarios
and mercenaries to the already packed
lineup gloomhaven can be played alone or
with up to 4 players online regardless
of what platform you play on if this
sounds like your kind of game gloomhaven
hits PS4 and 5 the Xboxes and switch on
September 18th and as twin sales have
kindly sponsored this video there's also
a link in the description
[Music]
three games this month 2 with no strings
attached and a couple linked to PS plus
and Game Pass firstly as I'm saying this
it appears that one of September's PS
plus essential games has been leaked
Saints Row the 2022 reboot is
essentially a kinda janky GTA 5 clone
that said playing this in Co-op is
honestly some of the dumbest fun I've
had in a long time I'll talk more about
this in depth when Sony confirm it but I
thought you'd like a heads up speaking
of PS plus remember that sea of stars
releases on August 29th a retro inspired
RPG that honestly deserves some
attention we play as a couple of Heroes
who can harness the power of the Sun and
Moon and bringing this up because it
didn't release at the same time as the
other PS plus extra games and I don't
want you to miss it
and here's a few games that are totally
free to play and don't require a
subscription service first up is Disney
speed Dom a free-to-play cart racer that
is trying to be the Mario Kart of Disney
properties the multitude of races have
access to their own unique abilities and
unlike other races those skills can be
used in more than one way the activation
button can be tapped or charged for
example Buzz Lightyear he can strap a
rocket to his car for a speed boost by
pressing the button whereas holding it
will send that rocket backwards into
other drivers the tracks themselves are
themed like the much-loved movies and
shows you watched most of your life a
thing to note in speech Dom is a gacha
element like those seen in gentian
Impact a way into your wallet using a
multitude of currencies oh and one last
thing speedstorm has four player split
screen on current gen platforms and two
play split screen on last gen so that's
PS4 Xbox One and the switch speedstorm
release is free to play on pretty much
every platform you can think of
including the Samsung Smart fridge look
out for it on September 28th okay the
other free game remember when I showed
you duties hacked a titillating Sonic
Style game that slowly uncovered photos
of well see for yourself you know where
I'm going with this now right there's
another version of this game celebrities
hacked almost identical in every way we
cut down the playing field to uncover a
picture while simultaneously avoiding
being hit by any of the enemies on
screen it's simple right and okay kitty
lock does look a lot like Tifa Lockhart
from Final Fantasy VII celebrities Act
is out right now on PS4 and PS5 and has
a bunch of very easy objectives for you
Trophy Hunters out there
[Music]
okay let's transition back into priced
games and a DLC that promises to fix the
many issues cyberpunk 2077 had on
release Phantom Liberty adds a
concurrent storyline to the main one
starring Idris Elba no less we fill the
boots of our version of v as he or she
takes on a high stakes mission of
Espionage and entry to save the
president of the nusa this update will
also drop on the standard game with many
improvements such as new weapons a
complete redesign of the cyberware
system a respect perk system new skill
trees vehicles and finally vehicular
combat and the biggest issue from the
original game was the police Ai and that
is said to be perfect now let's be
completely honest cyberpunk 2077 had the
potential to be a great game but it
didn't release looking that way this
update and the DLC expansion should
deliver the RPG first person shooter CD
projekt Red promised us night city is
calling will you go back Phantom Liberty
arrives on September 26th on PlayStation
5 Xbox series and PC
[Music]
racing game fans you've been a little
neglected recently well then have a look
at the crew motor Fest a sequel to
2018's crew 2. the game is set in a
large open world but this time it's a
Hawaiian island we arrive at the island
as it celebrates the Festival of speed
leading to multiple races and themed
playlists it's essentially Forza but not
locked to Xbox platforms let's see how
that goes playlists are essentially mini
campaigns which tell a short story and
really they're here to teach us about
the vehicles we are sitting in handling
is a blend of arcade and simulation
although the latter can be made more
available in the motor spot playlists
where Tire degradation and fuel
consumptions need to be monitored and
adjusted the crew motor Fest hits on
September 14th on the PlayStations the
Xboxes and the PC2 and now something for
those lovers of challenging games this
is lies of p and the first thing to note
is an available demo to play to fully
understand what this game is which in my
opinion it most definitely is a
soulsborne inspired single player
story wise this bit's quite genius we
play as Pinocchio the puppet created by
Geppetto we wake up to find the city is
plagued and what was once a lively
dwelling is now poisoned by Madness and
bloodlust with dozens of weapons to
unlock and evolve the real focus is
creating your perfect melee apparel
using parts from other weapons you've
collected and then using it to force
your way through anyone who challenges
you understanding the attack pattern of
foes and choosing the right moment to
strike is a key component and lies of p
is definitely one for those who enjoy a
challenge and don't get too frustrated
by multiple failures look out for lies
of p on September 19th on PS4 and 5 the
Xboxes and of course PC
[Music]
made it this far into the video then I
owe you dad jokes how about three this
time around what do you call a pig with
no legs that's easy it's a groundhog no
yeah no okay if that's too immature for
you I'll go even worse why did the
chicken cross the road
okay okay I've got one more what do you
call a magician with no magic
Ian get it Ian magician
I'll go I'm Adam you're awesome I'll see
you next time